[Musica]
[Applauso]
a cosa serve la scuola
vi siete mai posti questa domanda a cosa
serve la scuola io mi sono posto questa
domanda spesso soprattutto negli ultimi
tempi in questi tempi di di pandemia
didattica a distanza di
telecamere spente di noia di
assuefazione
a cosa serve la scuola una domanda
cruciale
importante può sembrare banale ma non lo
è
dall'elementare dalla primaria alla
scuola secondaria di secondo grado ogni
anno 8 milioni di bambine bambini
ragazze e ragazzi vanno a scuola
noi in italia trascorriamo oltre tremila
giorni della nostra vita a scuola a cosa
serve
io in terza
inter fa dicevo nel terzo anno del liceo
ogni anno faccio ai miei studenti e le
studentesse questa domanda a cosa serve
la scuola quando stiamo conoscendo c
quando stiamo iniziando il meraviglioso
e periglioso viaggio della filosofia
a cosa serve e risposte iniziali sono
poche poche rispondono i più sicuri
serve a trovare lavoro
serve a fare medicina ingegneria bene e
poi e poi silenzio un silenzio
inquietante non rispondono gli allievi
degli e smarrite sembrano smarriti
poi timidamente iniziano alcune risposte
ma
forse serve trovare lavoro forse no prof
serve
poco poco poco ci si annoia professore
sono altri luoghi in cui cresciamo e poi
arriva la risposta più
agghiacciante
non serve a nulla come nostra ma nulla
la scuola non serve nulla tremila giorni
di vita nostra scuola non serve a nulla
ma è una risposta vera attendibile sono
delle deformazioni
adolescenziali
perché è vero che poi cosa cambia dalla
primaria alla secondaria di secondo
grado perché perché alle elementari i
bambini e le bambine hanno voglia di
andare a scuola addirittura tutti
vorrebbero fare gli storici gli
archeologi geografi poi arrivano i
superiori storie geografie cosa succede
in quell'arco di tempo sette ragazzi
sete lievi sete lieve su dieci nelle
scuole superiori dicono che la scuola
serve poco poco sarebbe quasi a nulla e
si annoiano
noi da lì dobbiamo partire se vogliamo
cambiare la nostra società se vogliamo
migliorare la nostra città da lì
dobbiamo cambiare
da lì dove già un passare
bisogna guardare negli occhi questo
problema cosa sta diventando oggi la
scuola ecco a mio avviso oggi la scuola
è simile a un mostro sta diventando un
mostro è simile al mostro dell'idra
mostro mitologico della mitologia greca
metà serpente e metà drago e ha una
caratteristica queste teste anche se
recise
ricrescono per uccidere questo mostro
bisogna recidere la testa principale
quella che guida tutto il mostro è oggi
la scuola è un mostro a più teste la
prima testa e la scuola parcheggio e la
scuola in cui genitori parcheggiano i
figli in cui fini si auto parcheggiano è
una scuola pedagogicamente innocua inuti
si passa al tempo come si fosse un po
un'auto grillo si è fermato di passare
il tempo mangio un panino una scuola di
mille progetti
molti dei quali inutili e la scuola
della noia e la scuola che diventa un
luogo di tristi emozioni ci direbbe
spinosa e questa testa battagliata
questa scuola è inutile questa scuola
soffoca a scuola parcheggio soffoca
toglie il respiro
poi c'è la seconda scuola e da scuola
centro commerciale sempre un bel momento
la scuola si consuma consuma confluiva
consumare la bulimia rowe del consumo
voti progetti che di prestazioni
compiti di matematica e poi ancora
compiti su compiti oppure comunque
progetti anche qua da consumare
velocemente la scuola centro commerciale
e così caratterizza da tutta una merce e
si trasformano in merci tra le merci gli
studenti e gli stessi docenti diventano
dei distributori di merce questa scuola
è inutile una scuola piatta non c'è
fertilità è una scuola che soffoca poi
c'è una terza scuola che la scuola
azienda a scuola con le scimmiottare le
aziende dunque efficienza produttività
competizione ma questa scuola azienda
non serve neanche le aziende perché una
scuola ripetitiva coercitiva e una
scuola che soffoca la creatività e oggi
le stesse aziende ambito di creatività
perché prima di avere una persona deve
essere se non sei cosa hai cos'hai
produci e l'essere che deve nascere a
scuola che deve fiorire a scuola e non
il proprietario poi c'è un'altra scuola
la quarta scuola che la scuola d'elite
può essere pubblica può essere privata
dove hanno i figli della medio alta
borghesia quella scuola vincente non ti
sei ok se in e gli altri fuori sono un
po più i poveracci povericristi questa
scuola
non serve niente perché non miglior la
seta reitera le differenze di classe di
giustizia una società cresce se c'è
scambio se c'è mobilità sociale una
scuola quella dell it è chiusa e dunque
soffoca una comunità poi c'è la quinta
scuola forse la più perniciosa più
pericolosa è la scuola della burocrazia
il docente diventa un travet un
impiegato del sapere come se fosse
appunto un impiegato al catasto con
tutto il rispetto degli impiegati del
catasto la squadra burocrazia voti
presenze assenze form da compilare
relazioni da fare ma svanisce lo
studente svanisce la relazione umana
svanisce la crescita della persona la
scuola della burocrazia sembra uscita da
brazil di terry gilliam sembra una
distopia e c'è e c'è questa scuola la
scuola ogni cosa e se messo suo posto ma
il posto noi conta non conta qual è il
posto
conta che le cose vengano messe a posto
non funziona così questa scuola soffoca
questa cola uccide ma c'è una quinta
tema 6 st testa la testa centrale per tu
puoi tagliare tutte queste cinque teste
per far loro la scuola ma c'è la testa
guida e quella testa guida del
nichilismo e nichilismo che assedia le
nostre vite nostre comunità i nostri
tempi è un vuoto è un voto che tutto
avvolge in cui tutto precipita il futuro
il nichilismo se lo divora lo mangia e
ce lo sputa davanti perché lì cismo e un
vuoto un assenza per chi mi alzo al
mattino perché devo andare a scuola
perché devo andare a lavorare perché
perché sensi perché le cose muoiono il
perché è la risposta quel perché è il
fertilizzante se manca il perché delle
cose le cose sfioriscono bisogna dunque
recidere il nichilismo che un ospite
inquietante
per fare ciò dobbiamo cambiare la scuola
e dobbiamo edificare una nuova scuola
una scuola appunto umanista io la chiamo
la scuola vitruviana come l'uomo di
leonardo da vinci l'essere umano
vitruviano in espansione in più
direzioni non la scuola
monodimensionale di cui prima una scuola
in cui l'essere umano possa crescere
la scuola deve formare le persone e
questa scuola deve essere innanzitutto
una scuola del dialogo della maieutica
una scuola socratica a scuola si deve
entrare per conoscersi a scuola bisogna
porsi delle domande la scuola deve
essere il teatro del dubbio il tempio
del dubbio a scuola devono crollare le
certezze per creare da quei dubbi un
viaggio un viaggio verso l'isola che non
c'è una isola ignota ma quando troveremo
quell'isola noi troveremo noi stessi
perché ascolto di crescere come persona
non come consumatore nonché produttore
non come lavoratore come persona socrate
insegnava ai suoi allievi a guardare
cercare le cose che stavano sotto terra
o andare a guardare le cose in cielo
invece noi a scuola insieme i ragazzi
guardare quello che hanno di fronte al
loro naso spesso quello che hanno il
loro naso e questo telefono che può
anche diventare la biblioteca
d'alessandria
ma loro devono sapere che questa
elevetica d'alessandria altrimenti non
lo è la scuola dunque deve essere
socratica poi della scuola ecologica una
scuola che ti faccia sentire membro
della natura natura non è un mezzo un
fine noi o scioglierci nella natura
seguendo l'insegnamento del grande
immenso giordano bruno una scuola degli
eroici furori come atteone il cacciatore
che esce per cacciare il cervo ma
incontra diana la dea della caccia lo
trasforma in un acre da noi siamo
cacciatori e prede noi non siamo solo
prede e cacciatori in natura noi siamo
tutto non c'è l'uomo l'essere umano e la
natura
l'uomo l'essere umano e natura ea scuola
questo va percepito
sere natura e poi ancora la scuola di
essere un luogo del non voto
daniel pennac diario di scuola molti
l'avranno letto fra ci dice daniel
pennac in questo fantastico il voto
uccide la passione non una squadra non
valutazione i ragazzi e le ragazze dalle
vili e vanno valutati vanno valutate ma
non deve esser la scuola finalizzata al
voto al voto alla comparazione quel
numero freddo almeno credito per loro
non ci sia una ricchezza un percorso
altrimenti quel numero uccide la voglia
di apprendere dunque una scuola che
relativi di il voto che addirittura lo
faccia scomparire così ragazzi e le
ragazze a scuola vanno per crescere
devono percepire la loro trasformazione
che devi diventare
autotrasformazione e poi una scuola
della testa ben fatta a scuola non si
riempiono le teste a scuola si formano
le teste e tu di formare una testa e su
un vulcano
una testa che sia sempre pronta a
produrre un'eruzione una squa di jana a
scuola si arriva si distrugge il mondo e
poi cosa fai prendi le macerie lo
ricostruisce qual è il bello di una
costruzione che hai fatto con i lego a
meno che non sei un fanatico
collezionista e che a un certo punto si
rompe e tu prendi mattoncini la
ricostruisce dice che è bello il bello e
costruire leggo non puoi guardarlo a
scola devi costruire il mondo
decostruirlo ricostruito dei costruire
così tu cresce perché la decostruzione
c'è quell'afflato quell'energia per poi
costruire e uscire guardar le stelle
dantesche e poi chiudo
abbiamo una nuova scuola che deve essere
politica la scuola per i greci era
politica per i romani era politiche nel
mondo medievale la squadra politica
perché tutto è politica è politica
l'aria che respiriamo
sono politici i nostri cork e politica
l'agricolture politica il turismo e
politica l'energia e politica la nostra
sessualità e politica la viabilità di
una città tutto è politico e del
politico a scuola non è un caso che le
dittature politiche ed entrature
religiose vogliono controllare la scuola
tu invece devi fare a scuola il luogo
della democrazia
il paradiso democrazia a scuola i
ragazzi dello confrontarsi di non
discutere devono di battere tu devi
portare il mondo che l'esterno lo di
portare dentro a scuola così tu con il
mondo esterno arricchisce la scuola con
il presente arricchisce il passato
perché la scuola non deve ammaestrare
delle scimmie pronte ad esibirsi nel
circo tra scuola devi costruire i
cittadini e cittadine del pensiero
critico
la scuola deve essere l'ossigeno che ci
rende liberi
[Applauso]